the one you seek is done to people on
the fool
find kras matador under Taliban you know
what I love about Akira Toriyama the man
does alien names completely different
for every other author on the planet
seems to Revel in giving aliens and
alien planets foreign and weird sounding
names Toriyama goes the opposite
direction rather than filling his planet
names with alien sounding consonants and
vowel sounds like you're used to he
purposely gives alien things very normal
sounding names none of this then text 2
business this planet yeah its name is
namik this guy he's named after a
freezer and this guy is Boo it seems
like a silly difference but I do
honestly think that the more grounded
names Toriyama gives to alien things
really helps to characterize them in
more meaningful ways than them's aliens
I guess